no nobody knew I got away with it until
now
[Music]
hi I'm Brittany Schmidt and I'm here to
answer the internet
would you rather a sit on a cake and eat
a dick or B sit on a dick and eat a cake
B obviously sit on a dick and eat a cake
let's go it's called my birthday
if you could [ __ ] anyone you wanted but
they'd die immediately after who would
you pick I mean do I want to [ __ ] them
or do I want them to die more especially
it's like like Vladimir Putin take one
for the team or Drake okay
girl who [ __ ] kill Drake though
that's fine and you never get to hear
any music yet I know and he doesn't make
a song about me that's true that sucks
but yeah I [ __ ] up [ __ ] him till he
was dead maybe he dies because I [ __ ]
him so hard if you had to get one movie
quote tattooed on your body what would
it be
nobody gives it to you you have to take
it what's that from The Departed
Jack Nicholson yeah
is jerking off to webcam girls cheating
no
no no
let's all [ __ ] would you rather a watch
your dad [ __ ] a hundred year old man be
watch your mother kill someone well my
mom killed herself so B
if you had to move it to a different
place on the body where would you put
the vagina
the back of my neck
I don't know because then imagine a
gangbang or imagine imagine imagine a
train
I'd slip a disc
would you rather spend the rest of your
life blind or inside an Olive Garden
inside an Olive Garden are you kidding
me you can never leave 24 7. that's fine
I will eat breadsticks until I die and
that will be quickly I used to think
Olive Garden was like a five-star like
Michelin you know I was like how many
Michelin stars yeah would you rather be
a pig and be able to orgasm for 30
minutes or be a lion and be able to have
sex 60 times a day neither both of this
sounds like too much I guess a pig
orgasming for 30 minutes it would
probably be really good for your mental
health
and it's yeah more than I've ever came
in my entire life would you rather get
paid a million a year to have to work
ridiculous hours or be a hundred
thousand a year for doing nothing a
hundred thousand a year to do nothing
I pretty much do nothing right now for
free so
give me 100k in a minute would you
rather give up porn or sex for one year
uh well I don't watch porn so what
yeah I don't watch porn that's crazy
that's a lie what that's a lie oh no
it's not a lie I used to watch so much
porn that I was like addicted to it and
I had I had to stop because I'm like if
I don't have a good enough imagination
to make myself come I don't deserve to
come it was actually a problem
there was a moment there was like three
months where I was like unemployed and
just like when I was drinking a lot like
it would make me sober up like
masturbating would make me sober up so I
would just watch
until I was sober and I could start
drinking again what's worse being a tall
girl or a short guy being a short guy
tall girls are like models no I'm
talking like you got to be like let's
say like you're six six is it check
yourself yeah you still want to do that
yeah that was a kill shot to the short
Kings out there that was so fast
you'd rather you'd rather I mean being a
like us
three tall girls not fun though I have
freak tall friends that are beautiful
how's all like six three
and if they wear heels so they're six
six seven that is big yeah it is Big
it's beautiful
yeah what would your 12 hour crime spree
be during The Purge killing myself
I was just
thinking how many people I would want to
kill and it's too many for 12 hours so I
would just take myself out yeah
how long would you have to starve to
become a cannibal
this feels like a question for science
and not for me
you know how long you know it's the
zombie apocalypse
again I'm gonna kill myself I'm gonna
I'm gonna kill myself if it's a zombie
apoc people you've got to be ready for
the I'm like no help
Fistful of morphines yeah
my dog can eat me yeah I'm waiting for
any hint of it
but it's like how valuable do you think
you are as a person that you need to
stay alive
would you rather get caught masturbating
or [ __ ] your pants in public
um I mean I have [ __ ] my pants in public
so at what age
probably like
19. oh that's tough well I was like yeah
it was like coming out of a black uh and
then you know it's the classic you think
you have to fart in the new [ __ ]
yourself in a white Abercrombie skirt
I was at a house party and it was like
early morning it was like 5 a.m I was
sneaking out and then I [ __ ] myself and
then
then yeah I just had to deal with that
because it was like college kids who
also didn't have like toilet paper or
paper towels and so I just had to like
use one of their like bath towels
no nobody knew I got away with it until
now
would you rather have sex with a blind
person or a deaf person deaf probably
because blind like at least
I mean blind people can't see how
[ __ ] good I look
like this question really is a question
about how good do you think
yeah
you're like I've worked out I [ __ ] with
the lights on yeah
is 28 too old to date an 18 year old no
what's the cut off no to date an 18 year
old yeah there is no cut off they're 18.
you're you don't think it's uh I mean
yeah like legally but like are you wear
not by it sure
and seduce all of Hollywood by dressing
like a child okay you know I'm finding
out all my friends are [ __ ] kids and
I think it's it's heartbreaking to know
that they won't [ __ ] me you know I think
that's the worst part like I used to be
sad that isn't that the best if you're
trying to [ __ ] somebody they won't [ __ ]
you and then you find out it's because
they're a pedophile it's like oh it's
not me no
like I used to be heartbroken that
Leonard Leonardo DiCaprio only [ __ ]
like 19 year olds because I'm like oh
damn I'm way too old for him but then I
just realized I'm way too old for
everyone yeah I'm like none of y'all are
[ __ ] I was like yeah it was like the
me too movement happened and it was like
a really an assault on my self-esteem
thing and I was like is it me
like I get where it was I can no it's
not me are there sacred days when you
refuse to masturbate funerals tragedies
religious holidays no that's when I
masturbate the most
[Laughter]
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out